[موسيقى]
تتحرك شرائح التكتونيه في طبقات الارض
باعماق مختلفه محدثه الزلازل والهزات
الارتداديه جنوبيه تركيا في ولايه كهرمان
مراش عند الساعه الرابعه والنصف صباحا
بالتوقيت المحلي تحركت الشرائح التكتونيه
على عمق 18 كيلو مترا متسببه بزلزال شديد
بلغت قوته 7 درجات وسبعه اعشار الدرجه على
مقياس ريختر فكان هذا المشهد
ضرب الزلزال معظم الولايات الجنوبيه من
تركيا وهي شانلي اورفا ديار بكر ومالطيه
وغازي عنتاب وكلس وعثمانيه وهاتاي واضنه
موقعا الاف الضحايا بين قتلى ومصابين تسبب
بانهيار الاف الابنيه وضرر كبير في
الطرقات وانقطاع خدمات الكهرباء والاتصال
والمياه في كثير من المناطق التي ضربها
زلزال ساعات قليله يحدث زلزال ثاني قرب
كهرمان مراش وصلت قوته وفقا لمركز ابحاث
الزلازل التركيه الى سبع درجات وسته اعشار
الدرجه على مقياس ريختر زاد من اضرار
سابقه وضحاياه قالت اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه ان اكثر من 120 هزه
ارتداديه وقعت في محيط مركز الزلازل وهي
بحسب وصف الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
اكبر كارثه تشهدها البلاد منذ عام 1939
الزلزال وصلت اثاره الى سوريا فضرب
محافظات حلب وادلب وحماه واللاذقيه وطرطوس
وصولا الى دمشق التي شعر سكانها بهزه
ارضيه وفق وكاله سانا الرسميه هنا ايضا
خلف الزلزال الاف الضحايا بين قتلى
ومصابين وفق ما اوردته الجهات الرسميه في
مناطق وجود المعارضه شمالا ومناطق النظام
السوري
وفي سوريا تستمر اعمال البحث بامكانات اقل
لكن حصيله الضحايا سواء في سوريا او تركيا
ستبقى مرشحه للارتفاع